politik und märkte in sorge nach dem
drohnenangriff auf ölanlagen in saudi
arabien wachsen die spannungen
emissionshandel und abwrackprämien die
cdu legt ihr papier für mehr klimaschutz
vor bis freitag muss sich die koalition
auf ein konzept einigen
tod eines star designer luigi colani
meister der runden form und der
futuristischen fahrzeuge stirbt mit 91
jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag an meiner seite ist für
den sport norbert lehmann ein
sogenannter familie welche folgen hat
der luftangriff auf die größte
ölraffinerie in saudi arabien
der ölpreis ist weltweit deutlich
gestiegen aber nicht explodiert an den
tankstellen sind die auswirkungen bisher
gering und politisch deutschland china
und russland fordern besonnenheit denn
noch ist unklar wer hinter den attacken
vom samstag steckt saudi arabien
beschuldigt den iran und auch aus den
usa scharfe töne richtung teheran aus
washington berichtet empathie wissen
absolute sicherheit gibt es nur in eine
das war ein anschlag auf die
energieversorgung der welt aber wer
dahinter steckt das zeigen die
aufklärungs bilder nicht nur hinweise
fast alle ein schläger aus nördlicher
richtung das spreche für iran gegen eine
attacke aus dem yemen denn der liegt im
süden aber die hutu-rebellen dort haben
dieses video veröffentlicht das
angeblich den angriff zeigt sogar bilder
der öl-raffinerien dennoch legt sich
saudi arabien jetzt fest die attacken
seien definitiv nicht vom jemen aus
verübt worden so ein sprecher des
militärs erste analysen zeigen dass es
sich um iranische waffen handelte das
werden wir aber noch weiter untersucht
eine klare schuldzuweisung iran als
täter vermied der sprecher so wie donald
trump am wochenende der von hinweisen
twitterte man sei jederzeit feuer bereit
sobald der täter verifiziert sein
der iran bestreitet vehement jede
verwicklung aber die us-regierung gibt
nun offenbar doch dem regime in teheran
die schule
die vereinigten staaten verurteilen mit
aller kraft die iranische attacke auf
das königreich saudi arabien und wir
fordern andere staaten auf dies auch zu
tun hier im weißen haus tag heute morgen
das sicherheitskabinett us-präsident
trump ist in einer zwickmühle eigentlich
will er viel lieber mit dem iran
verhandeln als krieg zu führen denn eine
eskalation kann donald trump im
wahlkampf nicht gebrauchen andererseits
sind dies angriffe auf die
energiewirtschaft und damit auch auf die
uhr
wirtschaft und die muss donald trump
unbedingt stoppen
die us regierung will über diese
aufklärungs bilder hinaus weitere belege
veröffentlichen obwohl bisher nicht
einmal saudi arabien selbst den
eindeutigen beweis liefern konnte wir
gehen an die börse nach frankfurt zu sie
nahm meine zähne wie wichtig ist saudi
arabien eigentlich für die deutsche
ölversorgung also aktuell spielt saudi
arabien eine kleine rolle in der
deutschen ölversorgung laut
mineralölwirtschaftsverband werden auch
keine engpässe erwartet
im ernstfall gebe es auch noch
staatliche reserven angezapft werden
könnten aber davon ist momentan nicht
die rede
insgesamt bezieht die bundesrepublik
erdöl aus 30 verschiedenen ländern und
ist damit breit aufgestellt mit 36,3
prozent bezieht deutschland das meiste
rohöl aus russland gefolgt von norwegen
mit 11,8 prozent und aktuell importiert
deutschland nur 1,7 prozent des rohöls
tatsächlich aus saudi arabien die große
frage aber ist wie geht es weiter mit
dem ölpreis noch gehen das institut der
deutschen wirtschaft und der
mineralölwirtschaftsverband davon aus
dass der heutige preisanstieg von
inzwischen zwölf prozent pro fass nur
vorübergehend ist aber der preis ist im
tagesverlauf gestiegen und inwiefern
sich diese politische lage am golf dann
auch auf die preise an der zapfsäule
auswirkt wird sich zeigen
neben den usa und russland ist saudi
arabien weltweit der größte ölexporteur
danke nach frankfurt in am 1 diese woche
könnte entscheidend werden für die
deutsche klimapolitik in vier tagen soll
das maßnahmenpaket der großen koalition
stehen heute hat die cdu präsentiert wie
sie den co2 ausstoß senken will
während koalitionspartner spd vor allem
auf strikte vorgaben setzt will es die
cdu mit finanziellen anreizen versuchen
florian a
um fünf vor zwölf brüten die
spitzenleute der cdu im adenauer haus
noch über ihrem klimaschutzkonzept auf
der uhr davor haben sie das neue motto
schon ausgerufen
zeit für mehr klimaschutz eine partei
erfindet sich quasi neu heute ist ein
wichtiger tag wir haben heute einen
beschluss für einen wirksamen
klimaschutz gefasst das ist heute die
aufforstung der cdu wir schließen
politisch eine flanke
das dazugehörige konzept zitiert papst
franziskus der verteidigung von mutter
erde aufruft und es enthält ein
sammelsurium aus neuen und alten ideen
statt einer steuer soll ein
zertifikatehandel den co2 verbrauch
langsam verteuern
ebenso eine umgestaltete kfz steuer man
fordert eine abwrackprämie für alte
heizungen oder mehr ladestationen für
elektroautos
das motto möglichst wenigen wehtun vor
allem nicht durch steigende benzinpreise
wenn es zu einer solchen erhöhung kommt
dann soll dementsprechend die
pendlerpauschale angepasst werden um das
signal zu geben
wer pendelt so nicht kraft sein all das
muss bis freitag mit dem
koalitionspartner abgestimmt werden
dessen vertreter heute erneut einen
großen wurf versprechen die dabei aber
stärker als die union auf verbote setzen
zum beispiel auf das neue ölheizungen ab
2030 es muss auch regeln geben die dafür
sorgen dass am ende des tages alle
wissen das müssen sie auch beachten und
schließlich steckt der teufel in der
finanzierung auf die frage was die
vorschläge der cdu denn kosten würden
hat die partei heute nämlich keine
antwort das hänge von der ausgestaltung
der programme ab heißt es
bis freitag bleibt nicht mehr viel zeit
zu rechnen
auch die linke hat ein
klimaschutzkonzept vorgelegt sie fordert
ein verbot von kurzstreckenflügen
kostenlosen nahverkehr und einen
zulassungsstopp für neuwagen mit
verbrennungsmotoren ab 2030 auf heute de
bieten wir einen überblick zum start in
die klima entscheidungs woche was wirkt
wer zahlt und wer mitmacht
im türkischen ankara geht es zur stunde
um das bürgerkriegsland syrien
präsident erdogan spricht mit seinem
iranischen kollegen johann ii und dem
russischen präsidenten putin
alle drei länder sind an kämpfen in der
rebellenhochburg idlib beteiligt ankara
fürchtet einen neuen flüchtlings zustrom
von dort zudem will präsident erdogan
das syrische flüchtlinge die schon in
der türkei sind freiwillig in ihre
heimat zurückkehren
denn schon jetzt hat die türkei 3,6
millionen syrer aufgenommen
mehr als jedes andere land der
flüchtlings pakt mit der eu soll
eigentlich dafür sorgen dass sie in der
türkei bleiben
doch gerade in den letzten monaten
versuchen wieder deutlich mehr menschen
übers meer zu den griechischen inseln zu
kommen zum beispiel von der türkischen
stadt jazz mehr aus von dort berichtet
jörg brase rashid elgaß verließ seine
heimat syrien vor vier jahren er
schaffte es bis nach deutschland doch
weil er seine familie nicht nachholen
konnte ging er in die türkei lebt dort
mit frau und drei kindern bei einer
hilfsorganisation in cesme hier aber
fühlte sich nun auch nicht mehr wohnen
die verwaltungen in istanbul oder ankara
ändern jeden tag ihre meinung über uns
für die sind wir an einem tag in der
türkei willkommen und anderen tag sagen
sie wir sollten zurück nach syrien
alles ist ungewiss der touristenstrand
in eilig in sichtweite die griechische
insel lesbos
die stimmung in der bevölkerung hat sich
gedreht die meisten toten wollen keine
weiteren flüchtlinge aufnehmen im
gegenteil als türken möchte ich weder
sieger noch afghanen hier sehen vor
allem keine syrer
denen geht es ihr besser als uns die
sollen zurück in ihr eigenes land
diese bilder entstanden vor zwei jahren
genau an diesem strand 37 leichen
syrischer flüchtlinge wurden damals
angespült seitdem hatten weniger die
gefährliche reise angetreten
auch weil die türkische wirtschaft nicht
mehr so viele jobs bietet wollen wieder
mehr die türkei richtung europa
verlassen im moment ist stark wenn das
heißt normalerweise würden gar keine
boote fahren doch man hört immer wieder
berichtet davon dass die schlepper die
flüchtlinge in diese schlauchboote
setzen
in die lichter zwölf seemeilen entfernt
auf der insel lesbos zeigen uns auf
dieser reise schicken denn ihnen geht es
letztlich nur ums geld eine
polizeistreife hatte am vorabend diese
35 afghanen entdeckt sie wollten in der
nacht ablegen wahrscheinlich hat ihnen
die festnahme das leben gerettet
es hätte bewegung in die gespräche um
den becks it bringen können in luxemburg
traf heute zum ersten mal boris johnson
als britischer premierminister auf eu
kommissionspräsident juncker
doch von fortschritt keine spur
großbritannien habe bislang keine
umsetzbaren vorschläge gemacht so
juncker johnston dagegen zeigte sich
weiter zuversichtlich dass bis zum 31
oktober doch noch ein neues abkommen zum
eu-austritt zustande kommen könnte und
dann gab es da noch eine geplatzte
pressekonferenz
anne gellinek in luxemburg was war da
los
ja das treffen hier in luxemburg ist mit
einem ziemlichen eklat zu ende gegangen
boris johnson hat eine geplante
pressekonferenz mit dem britischen mit
dem luxemburgischen premierminister
platzen lassen weil die beiden sich
nicht auf den ort einigen könnten der
britische premierminister störte sich an
laut starken demonstranten hier auf dem
platz die menschen die gegen den exit
demonstrierten und verließ wortlos das
regierungsgebäude der der luxemburgische
premierminister musste die
pressekonferenz dann allein bestreiten
und auch sonst muss man sagen war dieses
treffen ein ziemlicher misserfolg die
britische seite hat auch heute wieder
keine vorschläge mitgebracht wie sie den
verhassten bags stop die notfall lösung
für die irische grenze ersetzen will
und so verfestigte sich hierauf bei den
eu-verhandlungen der eindruck dass boris
johnson diese reise nach luxemburg
womöglich nur genutzt habe um
innenpolitisch zu punkten um zu zeigen
seht her ich rede mit den europäern aber
in wirklichkeit gar kein interesse mehr
hat an einem austritt abkommen mit der
europäischen union zu arbeiten
danke für diese einschätzung anne
gellinek nach sachsen
zwei wochen nach der landtagswahl hat
ministerpräsident kretschmann von der
cdu sondierungsgespräche mit den grünen
und der spd begonnen
für ihn wäre das dreierbündnis die
einzige möglichkeit mit einer mehrheit
weiterzuregieren differenzen mit den
grünen gibt es vor allem in der
verkehrspolitik und beim tempo des kohle
ausstiegs koalitionen mit fdp oder
linken schließt kretschmer aus die
bewerberrunde für den parteivorsitz der
spd lichtet sich nun hat auch karl-heinz
brunner aus bayern seine bewerbung
zurückgezogen
damit bleiben noch sieben zweier teams
im rennen sie präsentieren sich auf
regionalkonferenzen im oktober dann
wählen die spd mitglieder ihre favoriten
deutschland gibt weniger geld für
asylbewerber aus im jahr 2018 waren es
knapp 4,9 milliarden euro eine milliarde
weniger als im vorjahr das teilte das
statistische bundesamt mit grund sind
die rückläufigen flüchtlingszahlen
insgesamt bezogen zwölf prozent weniger
asylbewerber staatliche geld und
sachleistungen die zahl sank von 469.000
ende zu
1017 auf rund 411.000 ende 2018 werden
deutschlands schüler immer schlauer oder
wird das abitur immer leichter
das fragt man sich angesichts einer
umfrage in den bundesländern
danach gibt es nämlich immer mehr einser
abiturienten 2018 hatte bundesweit jeder
viertel eine eins vor dem komma
spitzenreiter ist thüringen mit 37 9
prozent gefolgt von sachsen mit 34,6 und
bayern mit 31,5 prozent und auch bei
schlusslicht schleswig holstein sind es
mit 17,3 prozent mehr einsatz schüler
als früher
woher kommt das antworten hat thomas
garcia erfurt klasse 12 hier sitzen die
die oben stehen in thüringen gibt es die
meisten einser abi warum gibt es eine
erfolgsformel
vielleicht hatte auch die besondere
leistungsfeststellung eine bedeutung da
die schüler ja dann schon in der zehnten
klasse einmal seinen prüfungs zustand
eine prüfungssituation kennengelernt
haben eine art mini abi am ende der
stufe 10 eine besonderheit beim primus
thüringen und beim zweitbesten sachsen
oder heißt die kalkulation einfach mit
mini anstrengung zum erfolg wie sie
lernen ist nötig ich fange jetzt doch
nicht an aber keine ahnung ein zwei
monate vorher würde ich dann mal was
machen immer mehr einser abiturienten
das heißt aber nicht immer mehr top
studenten im gegenteil sagen hochschulen
und sprechen von einer noten inflation
wir erleben doch an den universitäten
immer wieder dass junge leute zu uns
kommen mit einem einser abitur und dann
müssen wir mühselig mit stütz kursen
sozusagen das nachholen was eigentlich
an der schule versäumt worden ist
häufige folge frust studienabbruch der
lehrerverband fordert politik und eltern
sollen weniger druck ausüben statt einer
für alle
für alle die gleichen abi aufgaben
bundesweit um diesen noten wettlauf der
keinen bezug auf zu den leistungen hat
zu beenden das eine frage der
gerechtigkeit der fairness vieles neu
machen die forderung damit auch die
schüler wissen ob sie wirklich gut sind
oder eben sehr gut
er selbst bezeichnete sich als besten
lebenden designer seine kritiker nannten
ihn eine art hundertwasser im knet
delirium luigi colani liebte es rund
fahr und flugzeuge waren seine
leidenschaft er entwarf kugel küchen wie
diese hier genauso wie zahnbürsten
katzenklos oder stühle ein genialer
gestalter zweifellos auch ein
egozentriker mit 91 ist er jetzt
gestorben in karlsruhe
christoph distel erinnert freihändig am
zeichenblock der stift biete und kurvt
ganz natürlich so entwarf colani und
quälte damit die neugier von zig
interviewen
ob er denn auch etwas mit einem lineal
anfangen könnte antwort also mussten
organische und griffig und auf unseren
körper abgestimmt machen heute viele
colani aber kam zuerst und war mächtig
stolz drauf visionär und angeber so gab
er sich gern der designer steht am
anfang der denkaufgabe und der techniker
steht an der zweiten stelle nachdem die
denkaufgabe vollzogen wurde
bildhauer und aerodynamik hatte colani
gelernt und ganz wichtig als kind nicht
ein spielzeug bekommen soll das doch
selber bauen fanden die eltern also
baute er ein leben lang erst autos und
flugzeuge danach viel krach mit dieser
branche tassen möbel fernseher alles
eine wohnung in den 80ern ohne irgendwo
colani fast undenkbar
bis zu 20.000 entwürfe soll es von ihm
geben überborden die ideen etwa von
einer ganzen bio statt und tiny häusern
als es das wort bei uns noch gar nicht
gab
viel ging die in serie und gleichzeitig
setzte sein design maßstäbe
luigi colani ein bisschen windig
ziemlich genial und ideen habe er noch
für 500 jahre
sagt er oft eigentlich ist der gebürtige
berliner übrigens lutz colani jetzt sind
wir bei der fußball-champions-league
norbert und bekommt es der bvb morgen
abend zu hause mit keinem geringeren als
dem spanischen meister fc barcelona zu
tun
superstar lionel messi nun doch im kader
die erste begegnung übrigens der beiden
teams seit 21 jahren die borussia hofft
auf ein fußballfest mit happy end
im fokus der bvb vor der partie gegen
eine der besten mannschaften der welt
kein nervenkitzel keine anspannung die
borussen wissen was sie können und wir
sind selbstbewusst genug um sagen zu
können dass wir das spiel gewinnen
wollen und weil es einfach auch wichtig
ist in dieser termin zielgruppe gut zu
starten
man spielt zu hause und man hat paco
alcácer in seinen reihen der spanier bis
2018 selbst den diensten der katalanen
trifft momentan nach belieben fünf liga
spiele 5 tore also ein torjäger mit
banzer vergangenheit gegen ihn
vielleicht besten der welt in einer
verletzung steht duell messi zumindest
wieder im kader aber selbst ohne den
kleinen flow könnte das spiel bei so
viel offensivpotenzial zum spektakel
werden
starker tag für die deutschen ringer bei
der wm in kasachstan
der dreimalige weltmeister frank stäbler
holt bronze ebenso sein teamkollege
denis kudla und beide haben das ticket
für die olympischen sommerspiele 2020 in
tokio gelöst
großer sport und erfüllte träume frank
stäbler ringt erfolgreich und bronze in
der klasse bis 67 kg gegen den ägypter
verjährt aber es sieht anfangs nicht gut
aus lud zu fünf der rückstand stäblein
nach nahrungsverzicht wegen
gewichtsklassen wechsel mit den kräften
am ende kämpft gleicht aus und sichert
sich mit dieser ein punktwertung die
medaille
es ist steht das fünfte bei einer wm die
tortur der extrem diät hat sich
ausgezahlt
ebenfalls bronze geht in der klasse bis
87 kilo an denis kudla oben weniger
spektakulär aber mit stehvermögen und
kampfgeist zwei zu eins am ende gegen
den weißrussen stadion auch kudla mit
olympia startplatz und medaille
es sind schon jetzt erfolgreiche
titelkämpfe für die deutschen ringer und
bei der volleyball em haben die
deutschen herren nach zwei niederlagen
erstes gruppenspiel gewonnen wie in
österreich
wunderbar das wetter fehlt noch an den
küsten wird stürmisch und regnerisch und
auch im süden kühler die details hat
gleich kontaktiert marietta slomka freut
sich im heute journal um 14 auf see wir
danken für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen unbeschwerten abend und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer morgen wird
es auch im süden kühler und im norden
wird es richtig stürmisch werden die
wetterlage ändert sich wir kriegen die
nordwest lage und da zieht so ein
kleines sturmtief von der nördlichen
nordsee über südskandinavien zur ostsee
streicht uns mit sturmböen und vor allen
dingen mit kühlerer luft die regen
ausbeute ist allerdings gering
heute nacht regnet es ab und zu noch ein
bisschen in der mitte deutschland später
auch im östlichen bayern und die schau
an der küste werden dann vermehrt in der
zweiten nachthälfte auftreten dann auch
die ersten stürmischen böen und morgen
haben wir dann den sturm an den küsten
sturmböen dort an wechselhaftes wetter
nordöstlich der elbe mit regenschauern
einzelnen gewittern und östlichen bayern
fällt anfangs noch etwas regen
der lässt danach und im westen wechseln
meist sonne und wolken der wind ist ein
thema zweite nachthälfte geht es an den
küsten los morgen vormittag dann vor
allen dingen hier norddeutschland der
dreht auf nordwest nachmittags auch über
den mittelgebirgen aber die sturmböen
bleiben doch vor allen dingen an den
küsten die temperaturen dann nicht mehr
so hoch im nordosten 13 bis 16 grad
sonst 17 bis 20 und nur am oberrhein und
am boden sehen noch mal bis zu 24 grad
die aussichten es wird noch ein bisschen
kühler regenschauer höchstens mal am
mittwoch sonst trockenes und teilweise
sonniges wetter ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut